here to co-pilot today she's a comedian
a new york times best-selling author and
one half of the two dope queens
please welcome friend of the show phoebe
robinson
[Applause]
hi phoebe hey drew
i'm so happy to see you i've been like
all excited all morning
me too i thought i'd do something a
little like i feel like this is
something that you will like it's a
little artsy
a little girly and i have a different
wig for you so i really came prepared
today is a different wig and i love
it and i love your shirt and i love you
all right let's get into some stories
phoebe i love getting to do the news
with you
phoebe do you ever look for signs
yeah i mean i definitely am always like
looking out to the universe
and just being like what what do you
want me to do the universe is like
girl i'm busy yeah so figure it out well
it's funny because
fox news reports on a restaurant in
austin that's helping their community
actually read the signs and as well as
have a little giggle
al arroyo has turned their old school
marquis sign
into some laugh therapy here's some
highlights phoebe
take it away okay so this one
reads in 20 years our country will be
run by
people homeschooled by day drinkers
which
i think sounds amazing so true
okay next phoebe um where is morgan
freeman
shouldn't he be narrating this or
something
valid point he should be yeah okay
next on the surface cool as a cucumber
on the inside
squirrel in traffic that is my new
mantra now
i love it phoebe see this is why i love
you and i feel so connected
i said this is gonna be my new mantra a
squirrel
in traffic
that's how i feel yeah it is
i don't know what's going on i'm hanging
on by a thread
and hey kitty yeah
i think now we need that in school
classrooms like squirrel in traffic
um well i love al arroyo for serving up
laughs and breakfast tacos okay
let's talk about rihanna and everything
she does
she just throws out the old rule book
and does something new and the world is
better
for it cnn style reported on her newest
savage ex
fenty campaign it features images of
story
and stories of three black women who are
all breast cancer
survivors and thrivers rihanna wants to
raise awareness for breast cancer
and the disparities in care and outcomes
that black women face and a portion of
sales
go to clara lionel and her foundation
that puts millions into education health
care
and disaster relief worldwide
why and how does this world deserve
rihanna
i i don't know because she is so
iconic she's so funny pretty talented
and she's giving i am i'm kind of like
can she
run for president of something maybe not
the country but like
of something she needs to be in charge
of more things because she just always
gets it right i also love
looking at someone who like dresses how
she wants
expresses herself and is like the most
thoughtful just amazing
do-gooder and that everyone can look at
someone who has the whole package
and all its different dichotomies and
that's one of the things i love about
her most is she just represents
a little bit of everything and shows us
that
it just you can dream be a great person
be cool oh she's everything that's what
she is that's what i'm going to say
rihanna she's everything all right
finally phoebe can we get romantic for a
second let's dim the lights baby
all right because the new york repo new
york post reports that a new study from
the netherlands
says that dim lighting might actually
decrease one's enjoyment of a meal and
they say brighter lighting
makes flavors more intense phoebe do you
have something to snack on
i do i have korean barbecue chips
i i have kraft macaroni and cheese which
is my favorite food in the world
so if this doesn't taste good in the dim
light like nothing will
hmm all right it's great
now let's um make it bright and take a
bite in the cruel light of day
okay
okay yeah it does kind of taste better
with with lighting yeah
i mean i just want to motorboat this mac
and cheese
but i'm gonna do that in the break
you